[Music]
hey guys Dimitri from the score eSports
now we all know that we love eSports for
the high pass plays the ones that
showcase pro players at their very best
but sometimes the plays that we love
don't involve sick angles or big brain
maneuvers
sometimes we just need a heavy old dose
of BM now for this list we wanted to
cover a wide range of disrespect from
the playfully fun to the historically
creative right down to the disgustingly
savage so prep that crouch key and get
ready to all chat some question marks
because this week were counting down the
top 10 BM moments in his horse kicking
off our list is the king of trash talk
himself who also happens to be one of
the best ATC's of all time double lift
now double lift is no stranger to being
his opponents just to be a cheeky boy
guys congratulations on the win and
witness win walking a bye for playoffs
but first off double it why are you so
BM man wait I'm not I'm not but if all
those no moment can compare to the one
that started it all
how good is it to get offense together
the LCS oh stuff LCS all-stars it's I
think he was in Europe versus North
America everyone else's match a defining
moment for both him as a player and
personality only grew larger as his
career moved forward if you play fnatic
what can we expect from that matchup
down the lane
Essam that's what you can expect a
one-sided stop and like I said I think
reckless kind of overrated
I don't even think that are that great I
just think everyone just sucks
cutie pie is basically garbage I'm not
gonna lie I've never heard a wait list
in my whole life
I'm sure he's pretty good but yeah I'm
probably gonna smash him coming in at
number nine is a mischievous strategy
that could only come from the mind of a
villainous mastermind yeah you're damn
right were talking about ice ice ices
1v1 kool strat from ti3 with the
anticipation of having to take on s for
months ahead of TI ice ice ice began his
preparation during dota twos frost of
his Christmas event the goal was to
collect several piles of coal an action
item that randomly dropped during the
event once ti3 came around his plan
finally came to fruition eventually
giving him enough ground to win the 1v1
this is the crucial first cream uh-oh
now he switches up with coal oh here he
is
ice ice ice has the better block he is
ahead and souls right now and he keeps
choking kamistan
it looks a lot like licking him and that
is that that's so confuse that is so
complete I'm surprised he still has that
was from diretide which is corrupted so
he's holding this anticipated in
darkness for seven or eight months for
this very special moment to chuck in my
god he's continuously right-clicking as
for is he gonna die on his own the god
oh my god first what happens at level up
see that is it 1 minute and 20 second
force bud I see is just playing so
crassly who needs regen coming in at
number 8 is arguably the most hyped
money match in Smash Bros history during
a national tournament in 2014 two of the
world's best project and snake players
battled it out for a 100 dollar prize
Rowlett the basic setup safe work he
understands thanks my well you can tell
you the training bro hardness oh yeah
you plan that computer to make it home
while the match between Rolex and
Professor Pro went six exciting rounds
nothing could compare to the first two
rounds where both players popped off in
the most bad manner to way you can
[Applause]
[Applause]
number 7 on our list is not necessarily
a single moment as it's become so common
to see simple knife his opponents known
for being one of the best csgo players
simple famously BMS his opponents by
sneaking up and knifing them before they
have a chance to strike back the way he
plays the way he doesn't respect
opponents is healthy for his aggressive
play style
it's traded back yet again and what
could be it Fox the leader of this
simple wats the night o simple don't do
it to it
while it's more reliable to just shoot
the enemy player when you're as godly is
simple sometimes it's worth pulling out
the knife to straight-up disrespect them
instead bomb down everyone chasing down
get to the dead in the chest just insult
to injury this guy is having an absolute
dream of a match taking the six spot on
our list is a perfect example of why
only a select few players are allowed to
BM with absolute confidence at the 2019
LCS spring finals TSM's ven couldn't
help himself from BM e liquids jensen
first the tall ad carry joked about
Jensen's height during their player
intro
[Applause]
but the salt didn't stop there during
the pick and ban phase then hovered echo
over and over again a champion that
Jensen had historically choked on it's
in a lane dominant mid lane player in
the block even on the world stage for
that marksman love it then every time
hovering a notable champion and a
notable failure of Jensen as expected it
will be the last pick for impact this is
gonna be the rest of the comp coming out
here then as usual trying to get into
Jensen's head but the effort to BM Team
Liquid ended up working against Sven
after making a Mis play that would cost
TSM the LCS title and ultimately pawned
him for the rest of his career can they
find those margins can they find that
opening so far TSM has outmaneuvered
seven no quick silver sash pissed
and shut down what is equally apparent
when Sven is under pressure there he may
have cost his team this series Rex them
sitting alone inside his face fictions
going to fall to rest his team is gone
team liquid tie the record it's three
LCS titles in a row
[Applause]
this is that opportunity they find a
picket even though Israel does have the
qss she is surrounded by so many members
that it just doesn't matter this is a
moment that span will never forget I'll
remember that because that he knows in
his head he messed up and he threw the
game if anything this moment proves that
while be aiming your opponent can be
funny at times it can also bite you in
the ass coming out at number 5 is the
well-known in-your-face lecture that Kay
Brad gave to wolf crone after sweeping
him at final-round 20 now wolf drones
been beefing with Kay Brad ever since
his look at that eye roll look at the
disrespect come on man so we you know I
can beat that
and thus marks the beginning of what
would become a bitter rivalry at number
four is some good old-fashioned Call of
Duty BM after beating team envy at Call
of Duty champs earlier that year
emotions were running high when these
two teams met up at UM G Atlanta I mean
the tension between these two teams are
absolutely huge right now the crowds
going crazy to my right-hand side
[Applause]
[Music]
simply put there's nothing more BM than
the trash talk that killa the choo-choo
train and epsilon dished out at you mg
Atlanta the match was so BM that at one
point Killa even put his controller down
just to dish it out this is absolutely
insane and you know what fascinates me
the most is how Killa can be screaming
as much as he's in standing up and
talking as much dresses and still
perform he has one hand on the trigger
and he still plays better than I do the
whole time talking [ __ ] and after
defeating Envy once again the team
wasted no time and reminded everyone
that they weren't going anywhere even
getting into it with the crowd
[Applause]
[Music]
look at my bank account look at my bank
account coming in at number three is dr
g's hilarious and creative BM towards
genius
after winning GSL league season one code
s clearly prepared for his sweet finals
victory
dr g swiftly made his way over to his
opponents booth and began dressing up
genius in a military uniform by placing
a camo styled hat and jacket on him
sending him a tasteful message that he
should retire
[Applause]
drg is victorious a huge fan favorite
for a long time now going over
he spent razzing them but they're good
friends in fact what is this time for
your military service for genius
I just lost ESL you're being mean
yeah all young Korean able-bodied bands
are required to do military service so
he's saying right now it's your time
do your peers military service because I
am the champion having the balls to be
em at the world's biggest eSports
tournament is nothing short of legendary
especially if you proceed to win the
whole thing
that's why Oh G trolling their way to
victory at the International 2019 takes
the runner-up spot on our list there was
certainly no shortage of disrespect with
Oh G spamming the chat viewless agreed I
think that's the Bill Kristol I'm gonna
be looking to abuse that in power and
give all the space the world where's
Carrie
nicely done man he was just laughing
that's not even all Chen that's just to
himself he's enjoying the plane here on
the big stage I wonder his teammates
everything recklessly fountain farming
and constantly throwing down sprays try
to round Thompson underneath the tower
taking a lot of damage the fee required
will keep he sprays loser disrespect the
other use of the spray of course is try
and control your opponent fly jerax he
gives him the spray where are you going
that's not the way to safety I don't
know what you're trying to do here ring
around the rosey all the way back Jax
give him the whomp he falls and died
upon the very spray he just planted all
that's gross but perhaps the juiciest
bit of BM came in the form of no tails
death stare
it is looking spicy grouchy right now
that is true their landing stage I was
skeptical in the start especially about
this bottom lane but things are looking
great right now
mainly because our taking the number one
spot on our list is the most
bad-mannered yet stylish way to
celebrate a grand finals win that's
right it's none other than fire bat
heroes Pro League 2008 final ceremony
after a commanding 4-1 win against gogo
fire back hero gifted his opponent with
the taste of his bland old rice by
flinging the bowl straight at his booth
the disrespect it didn't stop there
though as he proceeded to strip down to
his trunks while ludicrously dancing on
stage
and to top it all off he ran for the
beach to wash off his sweat after a
disgusting match by taking a dip in the
nearby ocean
[Music]
no matter what your opinion might be on
this historical Starcraft competitor
this Popoff was a master class of BM
well guys that's our list what do you
think did we get it right let us know in
the comments below if we forgot any of
your favorite VMO be sure to like the
video subscribe to the channel and we'll
see you next time thanks for watching if
you want more content like this hit the
sub button and bring that notification
bell for unique bite-sized videos you
will find anywhere else hit up our
Instagram Twitter and Facebook pages